ce matin les funérailles de la Reine
Elizabeth conclut une séquence qui aura
passionné le monde entier et fasciné la
France régisside qui cherche depuis 1793
comment réparer l'exécution de Louis XVI
depuis plus d'une semaine la monarchie
britannique est-elle des rites des
coutumes des traditions qui agissent
comme un aimant pour les téléspectateurs
nous sommes donc en direct de la
cérémonie d'hommage à Elisabeth II c'est
une édition spéciale consacrée aux
funérailles d'État de la reine Elizabeth
II et vous le voyez nous sommes en
direct de la cérémonie qui a commencé à
midi dans l'abbaye de Westminster 2200
invités étaient présents à l'abbaye de
Westminster parmi lesquels Emmanuel
Macron
Ursula Vander Leyens ainsi que Joe Biden
et Alan sont marionnettiste sans qui
personne ne croirait qu'il est encore en
vie
de Vladimir Poutine qui se trouve ravalé
si j'ai bien compris au rang d'État tel
que la Syrie et la Birmanie du Nord
exactement et à l'intérieur il faut être
modeste attendre humblement d'être placé
que l'on s'appelle Emmanuel Macron ou
Joe Biden
que l'on soit le premier ministre
canadien ou le président de la
République d'Irlande Hollywood est
enfoncé par ses Orres c'est costumes ou
ses parades du monde d'hier le moyen-âge
surgit parmi des smartphones comme
Godefroy de Montmirail est apparu dans
le film les visiteurs au milieu des
buildings depuis une semaine les plus
rétifs à la monarchie admettre qu'elle
transcende les cœurs quelle unie des
peuples qu'elle incarne une continuité
t-shirt c'est le plus moche que j'ai
jamais vu derrière on va écrire repose
en paix la clown vous racontez
d'ailleurs cette anecdote assez
savoureuse vous dites que il y a à peu
près 80% des Britanniques qui ont déjà
dans leur vie rêvaient qu'ils étaient
réveillés par la sonnette et que la
reine d'Angleterre se trouvait devant et
qu'ils étaient en pantoufles ou en
pyjama
récurrent chez les psychanalystes et
elle sonne à la porte et ils sont en
pyjama pour la cueillir c'est vous dire
qu'elle fait partie de l'inconscient
collectif de son côté TF1 déployer
Christophe Beaugrand dépêché Christophe
Beaugrand et pourquoi donc me direz-vous
parce que comme votre personnage dans la
pièce il est vérifie
c'est bon
[Musique]
le cercueil a fait un mouvement sur le
côté pour éviter la tombe de soldat
inconnu qui est au sol dans la rue de
Westminster
on peut pas faire mieux dans le genre
mais franchement vous avez le choix
entre la République et pour 1,50
symbolique vous avez ça vous choisissez
ça non vous vous dites ça parce que vous
êtes anglais les corghis les célèbres
chiens de la reine sont à l'entrée du
château une communication pensée et
maîtrisée au cours d'eau pour revenir à
2014 et à ce dîner d'état vous vous
souvenez du menu que j'avais choisi son
menu de prédilection choisi un menu
français parce qu'elle aime bien mais un
menu plus léger un poisson d'accord on
n'aura pas la recette aujourd'hui
éventuellement pour rendre hommage à la
reine on aurait pu cuisiner
[Rires]
un besoin de faire des phrases
pas la vraie
pas la vraie c'est bon je remercie
Florian et je vois que sans doute vous
avez fait votre marché à Londres puisque
je ne vous connaissais pas cette
imperméable à Paris
que je trouve très anglais non que je te
fais que je trouve très anglais pour
tout vous dire et je l'ai acheté il y a
plusieurs mois
Louis Vuitton d'un chapeau de la Maison
Michel avec une une
comment dire le voilette le sage qui est
en fait une broderie et des boucles
d'oreilles qui sont de la maison mais
les rio di Meller et des gants de la
maison Fabre voilà tout le tout elle
représente vraiment la France dans dans
la haute couture
carrément tu veux voir tes jambes au
moins tu es belle jambe lors du
Chamberlin que vous voyez ici qui va
briser sa baguette d'office et va la
placer sur le cercueil et cela afin de
créer une symétrie avec les trois
instruments d'État qui ont été retirés
c'est-à-dire le 7 l'homme et la couronne
impériale d'État voilà l'ordre
chamberling qui symboliquement brise sa
baguette d'office je vais vous dire je
regrette que ça s'arrête mais je ne
devrais pas le dire comme ça je suis
aimanté depuis huit jours par ces images
je pense que faudrait que j'aille voir
un psychanalyste
[Musique]
de longs files d'attente on les a vu des
normes rassemblements là au Royaume-Uni
des gens collé-serrés ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait pas vu mais
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
[Rires]
si vous faites une file d'attente avec
des Français je suis pas sûr que ça se
passe comme ça se passe très vieilles
souches j'irai pas sur ce terrain là non
plus et je retire ce que vous avez dit
parce que je le modérateur que je sais
que je suis ne vous laissera pas dire ça
parce que je ne souhaite pas stigmatiser
une population une partie de la
population ou non
moi je préfère les enterrements au
mariage quand même par exemple mais je
trouve pas que c'est plus sympa les
enterrements je déteste les mariages j'y
vais pas d'ailleurs ce type est malade
il faut y penser cette joie obligatoire
le dîner dégueulasse les trucs mal
organisés l'hôtel qui a des plombes du
lieu où ça c'est l'horreur je teste ça